raccontare di quella volta in cui mi
sono inclinata una costola perché 8 sito
mai creato dire che siano già non sono
rotte però insomma sono danneggiate non
dire ciao ragazzi bentornati una puntata
di vita buttata il tema della puntata di
oggi è modi stupidi in cui mi sono fatto
male
vivi per miracolo morti per poco migli
l'idea per questa poi è di settimane fa
mentre ascoltava rds ora non ricordo chi
aveva tirato un tema simile fuori e i
messaggi erano stati molto per inguine
ho pensato di replicare queste da qui
sul canale quindi shutout rds grazie
mille
ma per ottava si importante ho pensato
di invitare all'interno degli studi
queste casa mia una persona che cerco di
tenere lontano il più possibile in
realtà dalla mia dimora ma che purtroppo
ogni tanto invito più per diciamo un
ritorno personale che per un piacere di
passare del tempo con lei sto parlando
della mia compagna di banco nonché miei
compagni in bianco sembra che c'è ancora
16 anni
va bene colei che mi ha fatto passare
alla maturità stella polare ma in
generale stella di vita backup non
sarebbe detto lo sai
rieccoci qui allora sei pronta io poi mi
sono ricordato che poi tu hai avuto un
modo stupido in quelle si è fatta male
io divario così ma apertura avevo perché
abbiamo messo la rimandato
ho detto sai che cosa sicuramente lei
tirerà fuori degli aneddoti di me da
ragazzo quando ero stupito inguardabile
e shock su questo tema che è di stupido
inguardabile parte già emerso
chiaramente nella mente è un periodo in
cui lo riesco a parlare contenuto che va
avanti da una trentina d'anni
specializza dolori bizzarri allora in
salsa dolori bizzarri sono stati
raccolti di cotone presi sono tesi a
vuoto quel giorno penso come te lo stop
mare non sa di aver preso un
enterogermina ricordate se vorrà di
confronto a cuore la città piaciuto un
po mentre lo siano in atto dal tar
ascoltano in attesa un trapiantato con
la terra errore pazzesco che te lo forte
paura mi sono tirato addosso un
appuntamento
mi chiedo come mai lei non la mia
richiamato subito attivo che in serata
il numero per un momento in realtà
all'ansia che andando in altalena tipo
la forza centrifuga avesse fatto tipo
effetto è presente legge si metta
io ho due episodi da raccontarvi uno è
stato impiegarmi il labbro superiore
nelle bacchette dell'ombrello
l'altro episodio è successo che per
farmi dare i soldi dei miei genitori no
quella cosa del topino dei denti mi sono
scusato mi sono staccato in mente un
angolino di del muro di casa
praticamente ma ci aspettino che bella
versione cat e figlia per le truffe dei
versi di nuovo a sbatterlo fino a quando
non cadeva non è mai caduto questo dente
mi si è soltanto storto e io non ho
visto usato il 20 della storia così un
po grado di questi non sara baldi
ridicoli sono di pochi iscritti mucchio
cielo una volta in cui mi sono fatto
male in un modo assurdo e l'accortezza
per guidare il motorino
c'è un cile pubblicata da ferma e io ero
incastrato sotto il motorino quindi non
potevo dissimulare fuggire come avrei
voluto e non aveva nessun valore non
sapevo per spiegare ero solo cretinate
scivolata era bagnato non era niente era
che cosa vuoi guidare ma cosa vi temere
e me lo ricordo ma tu non mi hai detto
che c'era tipo del brecciolino sta
ricercando dice e sono caduta moli
circostanza non è soltanto e spesso ero
a scuola presentava delle scuole medie e
per questo non era stato previsto questa
citazione anche insedio c'era stato
spiegato che a suonare della campanella
avremmo dovuto nascondersi tutti i
banchi in seguito trascorsi 15 minuti
sirentina per vere all'aula fine
nel cortile della scuola bene nei
momenti in cui la campanella suona io
faccio per nascondermi fatto il manzoni
dono anche un'occhiata sul naso tornando
mi una violenta e ti stai chiede stato
quelle in un'estensione realizzato che
se veramente ci fosse stato un incendio
probabilmente io mi ricordo che una
volta da piccolino mi sono fatto male da
solo ma il mio ricordo è difficile da
piazzare nel contesto della realtà e
della possibilità ma l'insieme
rendimenti no ero piccolo vado avanti
c'era una fiamma ossidrica io l'ho
toccata casualmente sarà una via ma lo
ricordo comunque era in un ambiente
volta si cura famigliare a caso il
creato e ciao spie fatto coldiretti che
ogni giorno combatto contro me stessa
per non farmi nel mare oggi racconta di
quella volta che d'estate
mio padre mi portava sempre la colazione
e mia lasciava fuori dalla porta sulla
maniglia così
ad aprire la porta che prende
lavorazione e non so come vado a
incastrarmi il mignolo del piede sotto
la porta blindata
cerco in tutti modi visca estrarlo
trascino il piede ma non per scanu
allora a tirare il piede così po tirato
ho urlato talmente forte che pensano i
vicini pensassero che qualcuno stessi
scocciato un maiale così precisa la
serie di cross e timo vivono e fatto già
con la famiglia tv il padre joe cole
rendeva le grasse farsi strada
per tutta la forza che allora io ho
un'idea la colazione era in un sacchetto
scusami le spalle a una porta della
camera anche una porta blindata iago è
già ospite volevo rendervi la specie di
quella volta in cui quando avevo dieci
anni ho creduto fosse una buona idea
mettete anche gli su una sedia le carni
da caviglia ad una corda che stavolta è
arrivata ad un albero e lanciarmi come
tarzan pesato però non è stato dei
migliori visto che sono finita a pesata
per a testa in giù con taranta questa
serie a fire albero perché questa è una
seria se io salgo sopra mi reggo la
caviglia all'albero e saltò giù io casco
di lato con un piede in su a noi che
meritava la corda forse ti attivo
l'attiva dall'altro lato e la beta
legalità non si legavano i cavalieri
nostro paese
c'erano tanti modi per renderla
un'esperienza piacevole se riuscito a
trovarne uno dei siti ma lei non lo sa
poco
vabbè se facevo il cappio no no no certo
seguiamo miliardo lo facciamo un cappio
no facevi tipo un certo che non si
chiude come si chiama infilarmi
solamente la pietra del pm dai sacchetti
non trovavi si no non lo fate
che sarà mai
sette punti c'e una mano soprattutto
milano fondi faccia da sole sono gli
altri anche negozi prende in pieno le
porte di vetro come per dire no ragazzi
sto aspettando e video quanto è duro è
carino insomma ci sono quelle di tipo
con osteno del m dal naso a scissioni
tratterà la tarantino e poi li aveva
definiti state le testate sono il mio ma
ste sia con le macchine quando entra
toccano mi fai venire voglia di
conoscere la nostra vita perché
avrebbero un pugno di chi non avrà
guardato male il lettore la vetrina è
vero il bicchiere è la kryptonite
distruggere macchina con mia madre era
seduta accanto a lei dietro c'è anche
una mia amica dato che la mia macchina a
quei tempi e va l'impianto a gas e io
perché da piccola ero completamente
terrorizzata dall'idea di una macchina
potesse scoppiare ho iniziato a sentire
questa puzza di gas
incredibile io ho cercato di avvertire
la madre e di dirle che ci devono
fermare premi a mother in aumento
ascolto quindi ho pensato bene mentre la
macchina era in moto di aprire lo
sportello e ville letteralmente fuori
dalla macchina mi sono fatta malissimo
nessun danno grave per fortuna è inutile
dire che ne ho messo tutto bene perché
finisce bene non so se capita anche a te
io sento puzza di casa di gaza sento
puzza di gas un sacco di volte a tutti
capita di andare in un corridoio sentire
latus la bassa problema comunque aspetta
la migliore ricordata un'altra rivolta
al cui solo caduta bisogna fatta
malissimo e darà portando le lastre
all'ospedale
salman dal policlinico o portare le
lastre al ginocchio al reumatologo
merano e sono scivolato merchiori a
pellizotti cantoni le vostre avranno
frattempo era peggior assistiti aviatori
partner l'altro mi sono rialzata subito
ma in realtà mi ero fatta malissimo tipo
occorso attraverso dalla strada girato
l'angolo
dietro l'angolo 6 crollate un pochino
come un attrice quando ritorna dietro di
sé modico io di solito è sempre lo
stesso modo certo facciamo violetto
stava vincendo il cellulare tenendo
apache sopra la testa è certo punto il
cellulare mikati emili finisce
nell'occhio ma mica sei una di noi è una
di tutti cioè ragazzi succede a tutti
che hanno inventato quelle specie di
anellini per tenerlo così che io però
però comunque io lo faccio anche quando
leggo con i libri digitali tipo perché
poi mi sta bloccando con gli immigrati
svaria demo digitali slam del kindle non
volevo fare la pubblicità su quel che io
non intendo la bella comprava il team è
convinta di poter passare sotto i
tabelloni e con scritto il nome della
stazione detto che sono bassa senza
piegarmi quindi morale partecipato
allucinante contro il cartellone perché
c'è una massa ma non così tanto basta
tu hai preso il palo di fondo di via
delle valli con i roller brad non ha
preso il palo tipo hai fatto una ca ta
legge ma ho fatto una cosa pazzesca
va bene parliamone grazie vi ringrazio
per questa opportunità
io lì mi sono salvato la vita in maniera
epica periodo di parole il prete ram
oggi va benissimo stavo con i roller
blade runner premio per un tipo di pane
alla fine di questa di questo ponte c'è
una discesa una discesa che non
ricordavo la discesa non era un problema
il problema era che le norme incrocio
che c'è dopo che prima di questa discesa
c'è una specie di scalino quindi io vedo
che c'è lo scalino e dico porc
l'unica cosa che posso fare è farmi male
quindi tanto vale saltare salto eri
atterro in piedi pazzesco acquistando
sempre più velocità e dante il match all
incrocio con delle macchine ed è stato
lì che io mi sono lanciato abbracciato
valle a bracciano infatti preso in
faccia prendenti dalla macchina ed anzi
avevamo un bellissimo ha venduto e molti
video in meno esatto ho dato cacciavite
ed ai sensi e per questo motivo mi sono
82 del piede e limitare la nostra di
luna siamo arrivati alla fine di questa
puntata io ringrazio mega per essersi
prestata altre piene di emozioni e
soprattutto piena di parole che non
riuscivano quindi se ringrazio per
avermi fatto un pochino da correttore
automatico
ringrazio anche voi che avete mandato i
messaggi che avete seguito questo video
fatemi sapere quali sono stati i modi
assurdi in cui vi siete fatti male ma
soprattutto quelli più stupidi in
assoluto se vi è piaciuto questo video
iscrivetevi a questo canale attivatela
campanellina delle notifiche per non
perdervi altri video ma la realta
gli albumi e regionali è ritornato
dell'italiano regalato in un dizionario
e che dire ci vediamo al prossimo
giovedì diciamo sì abbiamo più il
prossimo giovedì sempre le 14 con un
nuovo episodio di vita buttata ciao ciao